who does who does which more do women
lie about their body counts more often
than men lie about their jobs
women have jobs to lie about oh come on
can we speak on the fact that some men
are making things up no men make more
than women maybe the men you deal with
most of them I'm talking about
personally as a whole like
generalization like as men sometimes
they do have like you know like you
would say like paid not good working
paying jobs where I was in the council
with I don't know 50 000 more than women
yeah for that men do that because they
need to hold a status like in in a lot
of men's minds they meant to be the home
bringer right but my point is like who
lies about which more anybody lies man
what's your body pounds what's your body
count
okay forget that would you tell somebody
that you're just meeting or just
beginning today your body count I've
never lied to
um a boyfriend about it good like I I
just I feel like you should be honest if
it wasn't a boyfriend like a guy was
like approaching you was kind of like
you know never told no random guy never
here but like people scared to know like
maybe he's your boyfriend but you've
been seeing each other a couple times
you tell him but he won't become your
man unless you tell him your body count
not as you just no no no no so okay okay
so listen if I'm dating you we're dating
for six months seven eight yeah okay and
you ask me no first of all there's
another energy that we do you see a lot
of times of men we don't have to ask
because we can feel the energy you know
you know you can feel the energy right A
lot of times when the girls had a lot of
bodies they come off a lot of trauma and
it and it comes out in a way to interact
with men you can feel it the room can
feel it the energy is so when we feel
this we know so we already know it's not
gonna be a long-term thing but then
there's other ones you can't necessarily
and you're like you're gonna give the
girl the one opportunity and I said I
want to feel like Kanye this the reason
I say I want to feel like corn is
because when Kanye married Kim he knew
egg listen he knew exactly exactly what
he was getting into this is why I don't
if you cry if he's crying now you're
crying what are you crying for bro you
know what he's doing here so that means
that he could not step into a room and
he did not know nothing about about her
so no one can come and embarrass her a
lot what a lot of girls do is they like
a guy and then they don't want to tell
the full truth so they start the
relationship built upon a lie but the
thing about lies is you know you know
I'm trying to say to you what's done I'm
trying to work out who these women are
because I'm not that one I'm not calling
you that but most women okay okay some
women a lot of women lie about the body
counts due to the fact that they don't
want to be seen as what men do as well
no but okay so why why is it whenever a
man make a statement about women we have
to say no we don't even need to
no okay no I'm saying but we do like so
it's just you know it's true what I mean
is it's equal okay so equally we do the
same thing okay so I don't think like I
don't think if anything equally
sometimes if anything if a man will like
up about their body count so so yeah
that's my plan so the thing about it is
yeah women control access to sex men
access to relationships so
I'm filled with a beautiful panel of
guests right I'm sure any one of you
guys will not have problem getting men
to sleep with and if you say you you
want your capping because I can just
know that already right because you're
all beautiful women right but I don't
have I won't be able to have as much sex
as you will be able to have all you have
to do is literally say to a guy you can
go on social media now say to guys yeah
well there you go right do you know I
have to do to no come on after putting
that work in that Finance right all I
got to do is walk outside yeah
well that's why they say women get what
they want and men get what Okay so
that means you are having sex whenever
you want with whoever you want versus
I'm having sex whenever I can get with
whoever give it to me completely
different thing right so if we look at
that then wow women's body count can be
but imagine yeah you think so going back
to your point about you said about the
body count thing right so someone that I
used to date he said to me that it only
matters to him as long as I haven't got
with his friends what do you think about
that that's wait can I give you a quick
just um I asked guys this question on my
show all the time would you rather have
a girl that has five bodies but you know
two three of them or a girl with 20 but
a girl with 20 but you don't know any of
them and they all say 20 bodies yeah
yeah they all say 20 and I don't want 20
buddies because loyalty well it's just
more like guys don't want to be
embarrassed like the biggest thing they
want to be an actor owner well it's just
like it's kind of embarrassing for a guy
to walk into a room and know that three
of his friends hit or like exactly yeah
so it's embarrassing so you have to
remember
I don't think I don't think body Count's
the only thing but but
um but it matters and that's that's the
thing like if you go from if you're a
virgin and there's different studies
that I'll give slightly different
numbers but I'm just going to use them
this one just as an example
um if you stop with if you're a virgin
on your wedding night you have an 80
chance of a happy marriage it drops down
to 25 if you've slept with more than
five most guys would pray for five
nowadays
and and there's some studies that say as
a virgin at 60 70 I know people will
come for me on that but but the the
point is still the same you're more
likely to have happy marriage if you're
a virgin than if you're then if you
slept with more than five it's like five
to seven seems to be when you're ruined
as a woman statistically is that because
you don't know any better due to
experience yeah yeah partially yeah no
it's because basically like like the
guys that are the No No the guys that
are the best most girls can't lock down
because how did they get to be the best
they have a lot of girls
and if they're good and bad like how
many girls you think are calling them
and so like that's why the the
equivalent like that's why I say like
they women swipe right five percent of
the time and they hate men because
they're all sleeping with the same one
because it's again 100 of women want 20
of men and sometimes some people argue
it's five percent of men like what
percent if you want a guy that's over
six foot what percent I need you to
cough out of the mic I'm sorry
um like what percent of men do you think
are over six foot fifteen percent but
don't you think that's creepy because as
us as females in general get older of
course we're going to have more
experiences so why is it you have to
have this completely pure image like
we're not a little girl but why of
course but the the problem is is that
you're not satisfied and the older you
get you can't keep those guys anymore so
by 30 you've lost 50 of the options that
you had at 20. so on dating apps like
they'll say this many guys swiped right
on you it goes down by 50 at 30.
and so the guy that the guy so the guy
the not really um the guy because guys
will filter you out based on age because
they just think the women their age like
they don't want to deal with they don't
want like kids they don't want an
ex-husband they don't want that stuff
and so it's like then the guy at 20 that
you know or 25 whatever it was
um that that you keep thinking about you
can't keep
I think it's just double standards on
this one you're right it is a double
standard but it goes back in biology you
can't change the things that men want
like like the reason that a low body
count matters is because
um historically they had to ensure
paternity so if a girl was sleeping
around like paternity tests are new I
think that's a new phenomenon that that
wasn't there throughout history so
um if they didn't want to pass on
resources to a kid that wasn't theirs
the same way like most women want to
guide their height or taller would any
of you date a guy five inches shorter
than you
no two two one one two three okay
okay possible but but not common right
the most most women like if they dated a
guy shorter than them it was one to two
inches it wasn't significant and so
that's because historically you needed a
guy to protect you and you can't get rid
of that like but you can't get rid of
your biology yeah but po look how easy
it is for gold to say I won't date a guy
that's
um five inches smaller than me but if I
say I don't want a date a girl that's
fat people start getting mad but no
you're entitled to your own no no but
generally people be like oh you're fat
shaming but I'll be but you can change
your weight you cannot change your
height like you're born that way so if
you shame a man for his height what can
he do but if we say to lose some weight
you can actually go and do something so
I just think like a lot of times women's
you can earn more money but you can't
reduce your body count
okay I'll be honest
[Applause]
yeah you can she can't change that yeah
what's happened has happened but you can
earn more money so the same argument
that you're saying that a woman can lose
weight but a man can't grow taller it's
the same thing there's certain things
that are restricted but were still
judged upon no but based on the biology
of what we want now but your body count
is your choice yeah so like that that
you had a choice in men don't have a
choice
he's born he's not necessarily true
though okay so we're not talking about
great okay okay just in terms of that
okay I need you to if you're gonna talk
I need you to talk into the mic because
it's just okay we're just saying with
that body count like sa like what if you
okay we're talking about the rule not
the exception yeah so we'll never so if
that happens we're never talking about
that just you know we know about those
scenarios we know about it but but like
when we speak about this we're talking
about consent consent yeah so we can
take essay out of that because we're not
speaking about that we under stand that
right because if we do then we'll just
keep going everywhere we're talking
about consenting if we're talking about
a consenting woman that chooses to sleep
with 20 men cool versus a man who is
born that way and cannot change you you
chose to open up your legs of 20 men he
cannot choose his height so it's not the
same
I feel like maybe some women maybe some
women maybe a little bit yeah sorry
sorry guys I feel like maybe some women
may be a little bit bitter or upset
because obviously
um men will advertise men will advertise
one thing but want something different
would give attention to one thing but
want something different like I've
witnessed personally like guys putting
up loads of captions every day or every
other day about loyalty hoes hoes
loyalty homes
but they like I know of certain people
they are attracted
which they may know or not know to the
hose for one night stands not for a
while yeah I'm not saying to wife but
there but like the attention they're
giving this home yes
the effort they're giving this hoe the
attention they're giving this whole the
entitlement yes it's for the pumps I
understand Pearl
um yes it's for the
for the one hit whatever but as wifey me
watching that Pursuit and then watching
him pursue me
I'm just gonna be like do you know what
you're doing no your wifey he's all so
women have to understand women have to
understand the difference between men
wanting sex with you versus wanting
actual commitment with you yeah I
understand something different but
sometimes it looks I know I know I know
but it's not the same trust me because
the outcome is no it's been put out the
pursuant might be but the outcome is
different so when men all chase after
these girls yeah versus you you're like
oh you meant he said he don't like her
but why is he liking the pictures why is
he doing these sorts of things that's
because he wants one thing what you need
to do is you need to separate yourself
from those goals so we get a lot of good
girls that chase the top 20 or bad boys
right so when you're a good girl what
actually happens is when you chase these
boys you don't actually become a good
girl anymore you just become the same as
one of these hoes because what you're
doing is you're putting yourself and
step by step next to holes and you're
saying oh why won't he pick me or why is
he treating that these are holes they're
always going to be holes and this is
what they're gonna do and good girls
have always been on the other side and
holes have always been on that side but
the problem is good girls are now
looking at holes and be like why are
they get why the holes get
it's a meeting strategy for men it's
like men are men are like they're
biologically predispositioned to like
screw as many girls as possible so like
they're it's crazy if you talk to like
men about their attraction floor and
like what girls they find like there'll
be girls that like I do not think like a
guy would find attractive but like out
of their attraction floor if you got one
thing if you got one body part that's
good they're into it like it's just yeah
that's true as many of you know I was
just banned on Tick Tock and we are
demonetized on a daily basis on this
platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible